president trump just so you know
the day comes where the world is
celebrating your funeral and and your
service to whatever you did in humanity
somebody that became very successful in
business and media and you were a
controversial figure that became a
president your policies were effective
but you you know people hated you you
had a lot of different things that
happened no one's gonna care whether you
die
being worth three billion dollars ten
billion dollars a hundred billion
dollars and i'm willing to say even if
somehow some way you're worth 300
billion dollars that reputation of
business nothing's gonna change
you winning one more time and coming
back and being able to redeem yourself
that's the true legacy and you're
hurting yourself when you do stuff like
this this to me made no sense with so so
i don't know what i'm saying so let's
just say the stack of truth social goals
and he sells it for 20 billion dollars
and he's 38 owner he gets you know 7.6
billion
who gives a [ __ ]
who cares